abby is with us in flint michigan hi
abby welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call my honor
how can we help
so i am wondering which baby step i'm on
and i'm wondering
whether i'm being um baby step two or
four
so a little bit of background um i
am in college right now and i'm in my
first year of community college and i
have enough saved for my second year
um plus a couple extra thousand good for
you and
i do thank you
so i don't think that i want to get the
entire four-year degree
i think that i'm just wanting to get my
associate's degree
and then go into the military but
i i'm just not sure whether i should
start
investing or if i should keep piling up
the cash
in case i do decide to go to university
you should keep piling up the cash in
case you decide to go to university once
you've made the decision
uh you can decide if you decide not to
go you have a pile of cash
okay that's not there's no downside to
that strategy
uh the baby steps really are for you're
in the middle of your education
process and the baby steps are really
for after you get out of education
when you graduate and you're working a
job then you work through the process of
building your emergency fund getting out
of debt and starting to build wealth in
your retirement
and paying off your house but you're
right now you have
you have really one goal uh finish your
education
if that's a two year or a four year
okay that's your only goal even like
with all my extra money just
just let it sit yeah i won't hurt any
account there's nothing wrong with
having a pile of cash when you are ready
to make a decision it helps you to make
the decision
if you're broke you make a different
decision than if you're not broke
yep you might go into the military kind
of sort of not wanting to because you
need the money to eat
or you might go into the military to
serve your country on a very noble thing
because you have a complete choice
because there's thirty thousand dollars
laying in your account
john what would you coach you're on a
hundred percent yeah
there's no downside your goal is to get
out of whatever education endeavor debt
free
and then you can make other decisions
later the challenge you're gonna have
is you're bored and you're smart and so
community college your first semester is
boring you
and so you're trying to figure out other
things to be doing
and just be at peace with where you are
right now knock your classes out
learn a lot if you can get an internship
if you can get a job in the field where
you want to be learning
go for it but um just follow the plan be
slow and enjoy your time
if you're gonna go to the military
life's about to change in a drastic way
or if you go to four-year degree and
graduate then life changes so enjoy
where you're at
okay have some peace you're doing it
right you're kicking butt you are
way way way ahead of the game abby yeah
here's the reason the main reason you're
way ahead
not only are you accomplishing these
goals with cash and you're building up
some cash
that's impressive but what's most
impressive is most
people just do not do life with any
sense of intentionality
and you're just being very intentional
and that's
really weird uh for people most people
don't do it most people just kind of
wander along and then wonder why they're
broke
they wander along and then wonder why
they got a degree in left-handed
puppetry that's useless
and they wander along and they go well i
got this degree and
you know uh gothic poetry and
you know and then i can't figure out why
i can't get a job because there are no
little
woods fairies hiring that's the problem
and so oh my god
you know it's just the kind of stuff
right so that actually did happen the
other day
but there's a gothic
guy who got a minor in gothic poetry so
um it did happen
uh higher ed as an industry listen to me
you're doing it to yourself
stop that's all that's all just stop
if you don't offer that degree we won't
make fun of you anymore stop
i'm trying to help you from the inside
here man stop you're doing it yourself
as an industry yeah so you abby you are
not doing any of that stupid stuff you
are
being very smart very intentional i meet
people who kind of life happens to them
until they're 35 or 40 and then they
decide
they have to be intentional and happen
to life and uh so you are you are way
ahead of the game
and by the way you have more of the
options on the table than are more
options
that you could choose than the ones you
put on the table so the options will
continue to unfold for you
and you'll continue to make great calls
you are a sharp young